hey guys so I am hanging out with
stylehaul right now and I'm about to
interview Kelly Osbourne now one of the
biggest red carpets of the season is
coming up so who better to talk to and
get some tips and tricks from Kelly
herself because this girl is a red
carpet pro so let's see what she has to
say
alright internet friends this is Kelly
Osbourne internet these are my friends
hi internet friends so we're chatting
about red carpet style and fashion and
kind of everything that goes into that I
think a lot of people don't realize what
our process it is to get ready for the
red carpet
no no they do not plan what it's kind of
like you're getting ready routine well
it depends really what award show it is
and where I will be placed on the carpet
for that award show and for how long
yeah but over the think this is my
fourth year of doing the I have learnt a
lot Rick's to keep you going because
it's absolute madness you know you would
never think that getting a manicure and
a spray tan would be part of your work
like that like it's amazing in that
aspect but then you're like oh gosh yeah
I've got to go get a spray tan and the
reason why I have to do it is because
for lighting you know I'm with George
and Juliana at George's Greek Giuliana's
Italian and I'm an English Rose like my
skin is pretty much see through
desp'rate mi make so I thought I have to
do it so they don't change the lighting
and because we invented the mani cam II
I mean we have to have crazy manicures
of every award show so I think it's cool
to kind of hear that because a lot of
people don't realize you think oh you
know it's so much fun it's so glamorous
okay it may be glamorous for a little
while but man
process to get to that oh is it
strenuous it no it really is but it's
fun it is really really fun like and all
the little tricks that I've learned like
taping how to tape your body in a way
that you can sometimes I don't want to
wear Spanx because there you don't need
to with the dress but I can't stand
seeing someone's belly button through in
bedrest I guess don't unless it's
sharing you're meant to now when you're
on the carpet I mean there's so much
happening how is it that people can
smile for so long like how do they keep
just smiling well I've learned a few
things they love the smiles because the
smiling pictures sell the most from the
photographer's bit your face hurts so
bad by the end of the day like right
here like your face just hurts like is
you smile into camera and like this
someone in your ear talking to you you
have a producer talking to you then I
get the image smile smile smile I'm like
sorry
now when you're doing all this red
carpet stuff did you have any tips and
tricks like how to pose did you ever
like I'm do learning how to pose because
I see them yeah they just kind of go up
there and they look perfect like how do
you guys do this well I get up there I'm
like ready to fall over on my shoes I
call miss J yeah
oh we do a whole session before like how
do I stand always make sure you take a
picture of your outfit before you leave
with a high flash because things that
are not see-through
I then see-through with a high flash Wow
so as far as seeing so many amazing
outfits so many amazing gowns who do you
think has been the best-dressed so far
this season
Oh without any shadow of doubt in my
mind Lupita Nyong'o has to be the best
dressed woman of all season so far yeah
I mean she has just knocked out of the
park every single carpet she's been on
but I'm very excited to see what
everyone's going to wearing thank you so
much for hanging out thank you your old
age so thank you for chatting with us I
look forward to seeing you on the
carpets and I'm definitely seeing all of
your amazing gown Eugene Ibiza
oh you bet you'll find news I was fun
thank you we're gonna talk yeah thank
you guys so much for watching I hope you
enjoyed this video I had so much fun
chatting with Kelly seriously I could
not stop smiling the entire time I
cannot wait to see what she wears this
weekend now you guys at home let me know
who you think has the best smile style
just leave me some comments below I'll
be reading them replying commenting you
can tweet me you can really just you
know do all the things Facebook buy
there any other special networks the bed
mist I don't know I'll see you guys
later bye